the self destruction of one of the
world's oldest democracies is taking
place and the great tragedy here is that
this work of destruction isn't being
wrought by enemies of democracy by
greedy lobbyists or sinister major party
donors America's democracy is being
broken by the very people who are
supposed to carry it and preserve it the
politicians what is clear is that
America is politically bankrupt and the
headlight of the New York Daily News the
fourth most widely circulated daily
newspaper in the United States on the
first day of the government shutdown
read this way quote house the chair has
heard the reading of the resolution does
the gentleman have an argument to
present as to why it's confined as a
matter of privilege in the rule 9 yes I
do and I was about to get to it
gentleman may proceed thank you as I
just indicated the headline on the New
York Daily News the fourth most widely
circulated daily newspaper United States
on the first day of the down read this
way quote house of turrets the byline
stated decease s pals shut down the
government and they get paid while the
nation suffers just today a new poll
came out that demonstrated as follows a
national poll asks the following
questions what you have a higher opinion
of Congress or witches Congress
thirty-two percent which is forty-six
percent what do you have a higher
opinion of Congress or hemorrhoids
Congress thirty-one percent hemorrhoids
fifty-three percent what do you have a
higher opinion of Congress or dog poop
Congress forty percent in dog poo
forty-seven percent Willa gentleman
suspend yes the chair would again ask
the gentleman from Florida to address
whether or not this resolution is
privileged under rule nine yes I'm
explaining why it's privileged under
rule nine may I continue
may proceed so long as the gentleman is
confining his remarks as to whether or
not the resolution is privileged under
rule 9 and should the gentleman fail to
continue along that path pursuant to the
chairs guidance the gentleman will be
ruled out of order and the chair will be
prepared to rule on the question
gentleman may proceed mr. chairman one
of the questions before the house on
this resolution is where the dignity of
a house has been offended and I am
demonstrating vividly that the dignity
of the house has been offended in
support of this resolution Matt continue
without interruption gentlemen may
continue under the guidance issued by
the chair proceed good the current
polling indicates what do you have a
higher opinion of Americans Congress or
toenail fungus Congress 41 toenail
fungus forty-four percent what you have
a higher opinion of Congress or
cockroaches Congress forty-two percent
cockroaches forty-four percent what you
have a higher opinion of Congress or
potholes Congress thirty-six percent
potholes forty-seven percent and finally
will the gentleman sir span once again
the chair is requesting of the gentleman
from Florida to confine his remarks
whether or not the matter is privileged
under rule nine should the gentleman
proceed in any other manner the chair
will be prepared to rule on the question
mr. chair that is exactly what I've been
doing and I would ask the chair to allow
me to continue without further
interruption may I continue a gentleman
shall proceed so long as his comments
are confined to whether or not the
procedural issue of whether or not the
issue is privileged under rule 9 mr.
chair I want to repeat one of the
questions to make that determination is
whether the dignity of the house has
been offended and as I indicated there's
one final point to be made here before i
get into further argument which is this
the American public
now the following opinion what do you
have a higher opinion of Congress or
zombies Congress thirty-seven percent
zombies forty-three percent now clearly
statements such as these and others
cited in the resolution call into
question the dignity of the house and
these statements are not from a single
editorial or merely one passerby these
statements are being expressed around
the nation and across the globe